[Music]
we're gonna talk about trash so why are
we gonna talk about trash here why don't
we yeah let me hear it
alright so there's a common phrase and
software garbage in garbage out but
nobody ever says how fast so we're gonna
talk about that today and why because
back at i/o we had this talk that we
gave called modern Android development I
have to apologize for the sunglasses the
Sun was right there right there really
annoying couldn't see a thing
sunglasses didn't actually help nor did
they make us look any better so we
talked about many things you know
Android had certain development
practices way back then and Android has
changed and devices have changed and
ecosystems has changed and now we are
recommending different practices all the
stuff that you may have known about
Android development may not necessarily
be true today one of the things that we
talked about in particular was a lot
about memory and garbage collection we
had certain recommendations there so for
example we said back in the dalvik days
dalvik was optimized for size it was
meant to fit in a very small area it
didn't have a lot of area to do things
like äôt didn't have plates to stash the
code really needed to constrain memory
the optimizations were not optimal
allocations collections unbelievably
expensive to get GC for alloc all the
time causing jank all over the place
heap fragmentation was a problem so
really the recommendation was to not
really allocate anything ever if you
could possibly help it and use primitive
types everywhere because objects are
expensive because you're allocating them
avoid auto boxing all this stuff yes so
I need to correct you once again you say
avoid the locations whenever possible
unions they don't yeah ok well it's the
whole point but but but but but but but
they take up space right so that's what
1 to 2 K you can't say video all right
anyway it's it's memory related so the
recommendation instead was pay attention
to art because it turns out art is
optimized for performance actually
getting faster with every release
because the whole platform was built to
be able to optimize more and more the
more the team works on it we're doing
JIT as well as a OT so
we compile this code we find out where
the hot spots are and we stash this code
somewhere so we can run that faster next
time you go through that loop
allocations and collections are much
much faster we'll go into details about
this where we have the ability to
defragment the heap and actually compact
as we go now and there's a large object
heap which means some of the allocations
amazingly faster and simpler than they
used to be so the new recommendations
are go ahead and allocate it's really
not that big a deal anymore still be
concerned for inner loop situations and
be aware that you are actually causing
the device to do stuff you are causing
battery and CPU usage so you still want
to be aware of these things but maybe
they're not such a big deal that they
should affect your API and your
development patterns the way that they
used to however that was like a lot of
really terse information stuffed into a
very short amount of time so we thought
maybe we should do this talk to actually
explain ourselves a little more
completely and say why is this the case
maybe talk about what art has done to
make life better the original idea for
the talk was actually okay well we said
all this stuff but wouldn't it be nice
if we could just write a bunch of demo
applications and show benchmarks and say
this is why and these are the canonical
results that prove our premise and turns
out that is really hard because garbage
collection by its nature especially in
art is concurrent there's stuff
happening in the background all the time
and if you want to trigger that thing
right now you will not be able to so we
made an attempt to write some demo
applications you will see some of the
results here but we realized we don't
really have enough canonical
deterministic data to show you so
instead we're going to tell you the
background of why it's difficult to
write these things because everything is
happening magically for you in the
background so first of all let's talk
about memory we see a couple of simple
lines of code here we have a primitive
type here is foo we're gonna set it
equal to five and then we're going to
allocate an object here well there are
different kinds of memory in the system
and different implications so if we're
going to have a primitive type that may
show up in the stack or it may show up
in registers dalvik was a register based
allocation system so it would actually
pop it in over there but whether it
shows up in the stack or the register
you can think of it as essentially free
it's kind of allocated at compile time
and says when I run this
line of code here's where I'm gonna
stick this thing it didn't need to find
space for it anywhere it knows that it
has space on the stack sort of you can
think of that it's kind of limited
sorry limitless storage space as well as
the registers it'll basically find a
copy hole to stash that thing it's free
however when you allocate any other sort
of thing when you say new object then it
needs to find space for it in the heap
which means it needs to figure out where
it's going to fit among the other things
that already occupy the heap then it'll
find space down there so that's the
basic memory system of the runtime and
the computer overall so the idea of
garbage collection well we've all been
doing garbage question even before
higher-level languages like Java and
Kotlin if you're writing C++ code then
you can do an allocation like this and
then you can use you can write the code
that actually uses that object that
you've allocated and then if you don't
do anything else you've just leaked an
object you're taking up space in memory
somewhere that eventually is going to
cause you to run out of memory right so
what you need to do is actually free the
object so you delete the thing you
reclaim that memory so you're basically
doing manual garbage collection here but
sometimes you forget that you freed that
over there and then in this other place
over there you continue using that
object and then you crash may be so very
non deterministic system you are
responsible for managing your own
garbage your own allocations and
collections tends to be tedious tends to
be very error-prone and so higher-level
languages came along so we have language
like Java where you allocate an object
and then you write the code that
actually uses that thing and then
eventually it is freed and if you
continue using it then you still have a
reference to this object which means
it's going to eventually be freed
without freeing it too soon right the
system knows what's going on you don't
have to manage this thing it does it for
you however if it's doing it for you
several questions occur and there's no
crash yay well ideally so there are some
things that naturally occur to you such
as okay well how long does it take for
the system to do this like I know how
long my malloc statement was going to
take in C++ but how long is it going to
take for the system to automatically
find space in the heap for me
how is it take to walk the heap find the
appropriate spot to put this thing and
then allocate that space how long does
it take to actually collect these
objects when a reference goes away when
will it be collected and how long does
it take to actually collect these things
and what impact is there system-wide so
if we're running this sort of garbage
collector thread this heavy weight thing
in the background they don't want it
what impact does that have on you know
jank on the UI thread or whatever and
when do these things actually happen and
also how efficient is that heap usage
right it's not just going to malloc
these little tiny chunks for your things
is probably allocating a large amount of
space and then putting things in there
and sorting them around and certainly on
Dalva because we'll see its fragmenting
the heap over time which means you may
have a lot of memory available but you
can't necessarily even access it anymore
so how efficient is that and how much
memory you're taking up in the system to
do all this stuff so we're gonna start
by taking a look at how dalvik collects
garbage dalvik was the runtime we are
using until android kitkat
it was replaced in lollipop with art so
this is a picture of the heap everything
that's in white has been allocated and
we have a few holes and we're trying to
allocate this blue object so a dalvik is
gonna do is just gonna walk through the
heap and find a spot where the object
fits when it finds one pretty easy just
slot it there things becomes become a
lot more complicated when it comes time
to collect objects so there's four
phases the first one dalvik has to pause
all the threads in your application to
find a route set so route sets are
typically local variables threads static
variables they're just the roots of all
the allocations that can be reached in
your application so that takes a bit of
time and during that time your
application cannot do anything the
second phase is concurrent your app is
running again so from those routes
dalvik will find all the objects that
can be reached and marks them as such
unfortunately since that that second
phase is concurrent allocations could be
triggered during that time so you see
here like for instance which is
educating sorry which is you just
allocated another object so we need to
pass the application again and find the
reachable objects again and all your
threads are passed so your application
stutters a little bit again and finally
we can mark all the
that are not reachable and there are
candidates for garbage collection so the
collection itself just gets rid of the
objects in the heap so now if we want to
allocate something in the heap and the
heap is pretty much full and we have
objects that have been marked for
allocation dalvik will go through the
heap realize that there's no memory
available and then it will trigger a
garbage collection for the specific use
case of an allocation that's the GC for
alloc and every time this happens you
see a log on KitKat doing adb logcat you
can see those GC for alloc messages so
it will you know run the collection gets
rid get rid of this memory then we can
run through the typical allocation
mechanism however sometimes your hip is
full there are no objects that can be
collected every object is reachable so W
over and through the heap can't find
anything and only two things can happen
either the heap will grow or your
application will crash and is the it's
the out of memory error that you've seen
I'm sure in a lot of real applications
especially on other devices this
typically happens when you're allocating
large objects I remember a lot of
developers in the early days of then of
Android felt bugs against bitmap factory
because out of memory error happened 10
tended to happen during a decoding of
bitmaps and they thought there was a
memory leak in bitmap factory the main
reason was bitmap objects are big and it
was hard to find space for them there
was no leaking bitmap factory whatsoever
so we wrote a simple demo application to
show off how some of the stuff with
heaps fragmentation works so in the demo
we allocates chunks of memory all the
way up to max heap so your heap starts
out very small and then if you can't
allocate an object it's it's gonna grow
that over and over and over until it
reaches the max possible so for this
demo we allocate these 1 Meg chunks
press this button it says there's four
hundred Meg's free you press the button
it's gonna allocate all these 1 Meg
chunks all the way until it grows the
heap until it cannot anymore you get an
error we catch the error and that we
know the heap is full there's no this is
pretty much the only situation where you
should do a try-catch on another memory
error don't do that in your application
and then we say ok well there's only one
Meg free so
gonna go ahead and fragment the heap
we're going to free a bunch of trunks so
we're basically going to go through
everything we've allocated and free
every other one through the entire just
go through every other reference city to
know then force did you see a couple
times to make sure that that memory goes
away and then we get this result it says
okay the fragmented heap size is now 200
Meg's
so we should have plenty of space to go
ahead and allocate a two megabyte object
so that blue object there it's only two
Meg's we've got 200 we've got two
hundred Meg's free so what can be the
problem so we press the button and it
says nope we can't fit that in there and
if you look at the log you get these
depressing things here where it says
special - error message in all of
computer science yes right here this is
this is beautiful it says okay you have
free two hundred Meg's free out of four
hundred and we're forcing a collection
so that we can make room for a two Meg
chunk and we're trying really hard to do
that and we ran out of memory so we
cannot find space for two Meg's out of
200 because apparently dalvik was really
bad at math the problem was of course if
we couldn't find 2 Meg's contiguous and
dalvik net I'll have the ability to
compact the heap you get what you get
once we put the thing there it was not
going to move so we couldn't actually
shove stuff to the side to make a room
for a larger object so art came along in
lollipop as I said it's a platform for
optimizations it no longer had the
memory constraints that dalvik did so
they could sort of build in a lot of the
fundamentals that they've been improving
over time but out of the box it came
with much faster allocation times must
faster much faster collections as well
as a faster runtime the ability to do
ahead of time compilations who are
actually like running binary code all
the time we're not constantly getting
things to find how we can speed things
everything everything faster one thing
you we need to make clear is when we
talk about education and faster
allocation in this talk we mean just the
time it takes for the runtime to reserve
the memory we're not talking about the
time it takes to run the Constructors it
has nothing to do with your code it's
only in the runtime itself alright so
how did our allocation work so in our to
introduce the new educator called the
Ross Alec and I don't know what it
stands for actually but it replaces
something called DL malloc so the L
stands for Doug Lee
was also the person who wrote I believe
Java dot util dot concurrent that that's
what happens if you write a really nice
algorithm then people name the algorithm
yeah it's the kind of person that makes
me feel very inadequate as an engineer
really smart
anyway the omec is basically the
algorithm behind the malloc function
called native code so this is what you
use when you call malloc or call new in
C or C++ this is the algorithm we're
using so dalvik was relying on that
actually replaced it with its own Cobras
so the main benefit of Rostock is that
thread aware so it's able to do
allocations that are specific to a
thread and we're going to we're going to
look at additional detail and you
understand why it brings a lot of
benefits there's also a lot of lis or
twigs that have been done so small
allocations are grouped together to
reduce fragmentation we online large
locations on pages typically four
kilobytes on modern Oasis and gives you
better performance also final grain lock
because the garbage collector has to
acquire locks because you know we have a
lot of threads running they used to they
used to protect a lot more code so now
it for Tech's less code inference faster
and overall allocations with ross
murdock are four to five times faster
than they were with double again this is
just about the act of allocating the
memory there's nothing to do with your
code you could do something really
really really expensive in your in your
constructor and we would not be five
times faster than phthalic all right so
let's take a look at how allocations
work on art in this new system so oh
sorry the the other very very important
thing with art was the ability to deal
with large objects in a much better way
so you've got this normal sized objects
it's going to find a space for it and
the heap over here and what happens if
you have this large open by a large
object we mean an array of primitives or
string and these are the the types
chosen because we can guarantee that
these objects and will not have a
reference to something else they can
live completely and it's from the array
of achlys twelve kilobytes yes and that
is the heuristic for now that could
change over time but right now it's
twelve K primitive types are string so
you got this huge object where are we
going to put it well in dalvik we would
put it where exactly right you can see
in this fragmented heap that may there
may not be space for it in art it's a
little bit simpler the
complicated mechanism looks like this we
just put it somewhere we just Malecha
space for it and shove it in there it's
not even in a large object bucket that
holds all of them we just allocate a
space for it somewhere in there and we
say okay you are now part of the heat
but really it's just living on its own
somewhere very fast very easy it's also
a moving collector so we can actually
compact things so we no longer have the
fragmentation problem however it does
this in the background so actually it's
a little more complicated my
understanding originally was well if
your application goes into the
background then eventually this very
expensive operation it could take up to
100 milliseconds may run that's going to
compact the heap obviously we don't want
to run that in the foreground because
we're gonna Jack your app all over the
place we're gonna wait till it's sitting
there in the background user is doing
something else they're not paying
attention so you're we're compacting the
heap for you that's awesome so I said
okay well I'm gonna demonstrate this and
show that same defragmentation a crash
error that we saw earlier I'm gonna show
how it crashes on on KitKat using dalvik
and it will also crash and all of the
releases until we're able to do it in
the foreground on the later release and
oh and this will be a cool demo and then
I ran it on L and it didn't crash and
the thing is yes it will defragment in
the backgrounds but it will also do it
in the foreground if it has to which is
really what you want so if you actually
need that memory now wouldn't it be nice
if you didn't crash that's a clean the
compaction is almost a replacement for
the GC for our look yeah from before so
now it basically takes everything it
says well you need space for this really
large objects we're gonna go ahead and
compact things and then put it where we
need to so on L and above we run the
same fragmentation demo that we saw
before we go ahead and Alec up to the
maximum heap size it says yep you've
only got about one Meg free and we go
ahead and free every other Meg know
about those references and then we try
to find space for this to may block
compacts the heap and puts it in very
simple so another improvement so
remember with the dalvik GC we had those
four phases including two pauses for
your application
so the puzzles were bad because
your evolution was not doing anything
during that time but what was even worse
was that those pauses could be pretty
expensive so on average the sum of those
two places was about 10 milliseconds but
even when it was only 10 milliseconds
that was actually pretty good I mean
we've done a lot of performance work
over the years and I've seen this kind
of passes last for 100 200 milliseconds
in some applications and during that
time nothing happens which means no
matter how good your UI is it will
janked like if the user is trying to
scroll it's not going to work well so
one of the thing that art does is it
removes one of the pauses so now the
first the first step the marking the
route set finding the roots of all the
allocations that are reachable in your
heap is now a concurrent phase it
doesn't pass the application any more
now on top of that the second one well
the only part that we still have left is
also a lot faster so instead of spending
10 milliseconds in there we only spend
about 3 milliseconds now so at most your
application will probably pass for 3
milliseconds which worked application is
well optimized even if the GC happens
during an animation or scrolling you
should be able to like reach 60 FPS
without any jank another thing that was
introduced in art was the concept of the
minor garbage collection so the idea
here is to keep track of all the objects
that have been allocated since the last
major garbage collection those are
typically temporary objects and we're
going to look at them first so if we can
reclaim enough memory by looking at the
subjects first because they are
short-lived we won't have to go through
the entire heap this is one of the
things that has an important consequence
for Android development where we used to
tell you never allocate even temporary
objects because they tend to be
expensive because they're gonna fragment
the heap we have to do the allocation we
actually the collection all of a sudden
we made temporary object allocation and
collection much faster and easier it's
not free it's just less expensive yes we
also introduced the larger break heap
that we talked about so you have less
fragmentation but one of the huge
benefits of that is because we don't
fragment the heap as much we don't have
to grow the heap as much in all the
processes and of course we don't have
those GC for our opposite I mean they
still exist we just don't see them as
much because they were very very common
in the dalvik test and also like there's
a faster runtime you know that's the
ahead of time compilation
usage it back but this has nothing to do
with the garbage collector marshmallow I
was looking through yesterday that it's
kind of a boring release because I can
never remember what was marshmallow so
here it is optimizations
things got faster fine grained details
things got faster and in N again things
got faster isn't that nice allocation in
particular they rewrote everything
although all the core stuff in assembly
and that turns out to still help in
software who knew and now we're up to
about ten times faster for allocation
cost when you compare it to dalvik and
now we're in our Oreo where basically
they rewrote the whole thing so we
introduced an entirely new collector
called the concurrent heap compaction
collector and this means that now we can
actually compact in the foreground not
just when we need to do that GC for
alloc compact to find a space but it's
actually running all the time moving
stuff around and optimizing what the
heap looks like so that allocations are
much faster and easier overall so
defragmentation in the foreground
you've not resizing the heap as often
because the heap is always optimized
because we're always sort of culling the
things out of it as necessary there's
far fewer GC fare always because we just
don't get into that situation anymore
huge savings for the entire device think
about it if you can only defragment to
keep when an application is in the
background what about the applications
and services that are constantly in the
foreground system service Play Services
system UI well we couldn't necessarily
defragment those until it got into a
really bad situation wouldn't be nice if
we could do it in the foreground so that
those things were optimized well if we
can do it for them that means we're
getting system-wide savings on the on
the pure heap size of all of those
applications so smaller heaps for all
means less memory in the entire system
and what we found was the entire device
had about a 30% savings on overall
memory requirements so we can take a
look at how compaction works in general
we have these 256 K buckets that are
assigned per thread which means again
huge savings in not having to lock down
all the threads to do these allocations
and collections instead a thread if it
needs memory it
just responsible for itself so a thread
says okay I need some memory it's handed
one of these buckets it allocates in
there and then over time that thing may
get defragmented there's a heuristic
that they have about if there's less
than 70 or 75 percent utilization and
one of these things then they'll go
ahead and collect it and empty the thing
out entirely so we see the T 1 2 & 3
regions here don't have much going on
there so we're going to take the memory
in there all of those allocations and
shove them somewhere else on the heap
completely empty out those buckets which
allows something that's super efficient
called thread-local bump allocator this
means that all we have to do is actually
just move a pointer we don't need to
walk the heap to find where the free
space is we just put the next object in
the next available space and we know
where that is according to the pointer
turns out all of this stuff put together
we're now 18 times faster than dalvik
for these allocations so we can see how
these allocations work in practice you
can see all these little colored objects
we're making space for them and the
different threads that need those
allocations if we take a close look at
t1
you've got the free pointer we've
emptied it out we've zeroed it out we're
at the beginning of that bucket and now
we need to allocate an object well we
know where to put it because the pointer
tells us and now all we do is advance
the pointer the pointer tells us where
to put the next one and the one after
that and so on so very fast and easy
compared to what we were doing before we
can see on the graph the comparison of
where we are at with dalvik allocation
cost compared to where we're not where
we're at now in O with bump pointer and
assembly allocations instead all right
so where are we going now it is
important to note that the young
generation stuff that we talked about is
being so awesome is currently gone but
it's back you know HP yeah what are you
being this your release yep so it's
important to note like that there are
trade-offs here like we believe it's
better overall all of the benefits that
you get from the garbage collector and
oh should compensate for the young
generation collections not being there
anymore however there's still a nice
thing to have so they're back in AOSP
so look for those to show up in a future
release so object pools this is a
technique that you know we've
recommended using in the past we use it
ourselves
X
inside the platform and the conventional
wisdom is that reusing object has to be
faster than educating them in collecting
them all the time and you can see here
we have a performance graph so the
x-axis is the size of the object that
you're creating or reusing in red it's
the time it takes to handle the subjects
with a pool and includes the time in
text tutors allocate and collect the
subjects and until n using a pool was
basically always a win compared to the
garbage collector but with all with all
the improvements we've done and this new
thread bump local thread bank local a
locator synchronize pools of objects are
generally slower and I want to emphasize
the synchronized part of the pool if you
have a pool of objects that use only on
one thread and that thread only you I
fix usually doing the kind of
optimization that art does for you now
on O so you might not see this the same
kind of savings but in general on O if
you have a synchronized pool of object
you'd be probably better off without
that pool again make sure you profile
your application before you take you out
and there's a certain memory size
certain size of object where these
graphs cross but this was in a benchmark
application that was really hammering it
and maximizing the bandwidth so the
general advice is you really shouldn't
use that especially the synchronized
pool approach because a it's error-prone
and tedious to manage and B it is slower
in general because that's
synchronization access tends to be
slower than what we can do now with your
using the lock in the whole point of oh
is that we don't have a lock anymore for
the applications so what are the
recommendations now creating garbage is
okay I wouldn't go out of your way to
create garbage it is still taking time
you are requiring us to take time to
allocate objects as well as later
collect them and you're taking up
battery in CPU and you're causing but
don't do that pick up after yourself you
should seize this it's pretty disgusting
I like to be a counterexample
so in general creating the stuff if you
need it is okay and so is collecting it
use the types and the objects that you
need if they make sense for the
architecture for the API so you're
building for the libraries for your code
go ahead and use those we are not
pushing everybody to use intend bit
flags everywhere to optimize every
little CPU cycle and memory allocation
instead go ahead and allocate when you
need to for use case however GC is still
overheads and we're going to look at the
demo that showcases that yep and make
the right choices for you and in general
the framework programmers we still are
your inner loop so we still take the old
practices because why would we allocate
if we didn't need to if we can make your
inner loop faster so be aware the inner
loop situations otherwise do the right
thing for your code
alright so wrote a simple application to
sort of showcase some of the jank stuff
that you can see because of allocations
and collections in this during the
ondraw I would call out to a method to
run some stuff and and in this case
we're gonna test Auto boxing's so we
have an array of a hundred thousand
float objects capital F float objects so
it's not just a primitive float instead
it's the capital F so we're gonna be
allocating these objects on the fly
here's what the the method looks like
that's gonna run on every single frame
it's gonna walk the entire length of the
array and take a primitive float and
stuff it into the array which is going
to cause an auto box so these little
tiny allocations are gonna go into this
array a lot of them over time because of
the auto boxing thing it's going to
cause a bunch of allocations and then
we're gonna need to collect them over
time as well so if we take a look at the
demo why don't we pop out all right so
we're running on K here we run this
animation we should take a look at the
log here and we run the auto box and now
we're calling out to that method and the
important thing here if you look at the
log so we're taking allocation times of
2824 sort of in general kind of high 20s
milliseconds and we're causing a lot of
GC for Alex because that is what happens
when you do this thing so we can pause
this one but we can pop over and see
what this looks like I know oh we can
run the animation here let me enable the
log for o we'll do the auto boxing and
now we can zoom in and this and you will
notice a couple
one is that the allocation times
obviously are much less than they were
before and also more importantly there
are no GC for Alex we allocate we
collect but we're never triggering that
that jank inducing GC for alloc in this
case there is a similar test that I
wrote for bitmaps so we're running along
let's take a look at the KitKat log so
in this one you're allocating bitmaps
and again we're getting a lot of jank
there if we zoom in on the log you're
seeing the allocations for these large
objects it's a thousand by a thousand
bitmap you take in 1213 milliseconds
each time and you're constantly
triggering these GC for Alex because you
need to collect the old memory to make
room for the new one so we pop over to
the O log let's stop this one go over
here run the animation do the bitmap
test and now we've got allocation times
of zero one because again all what's
doing is am Alex just shoving it into
the large object heap very easy to
allocate very easy to collect when it
needs it stump for that alright
that just duplicates what I just said
here's the bitmap test very simple it's
just walking through every frame it's
allocating a thousand by a thousand
bitmap and then you see the results that
we did all right so this is a demo to
basically stress tests to garbage
collector and see what kind of overhead
we get so this is a kind of a red tracer
using fancy physically based rendering
that I wrote for for my desktop
intelligent ray tracer because it's a
checkerboard with spheres that's right
and I ported it to Android and I won't
run you through the code because there's
hundreds of lines of code so this is
Scotland but the trick here is that
these does all water allocation so I
have a data class they float three just
contains three floats XY and Z those are
primitives they're not the the the
capital F objects that you get in Java
and here have a functions just an
excerpt of those hundreds of lines of
code and you can see it's just doing
math on the objects so I'm using
operator overloading in Catalan we are
multiplying
floats recalled ex by a bunch of
constants we're doing division additions
but the important thing here is that the
way those functions are implemented my
float 3 is immutable so every time I add
on multiply I'm creating a new float 3
object so those are fairly small objects
but for every pixel that we'll want to
render in that red racer we're going to
be allocating hundreds of thousands or
millions of this fruit trees so we're
going to really exercise the GC so then
I created two system images one on
KitKat one on O both running on the
emulator we're emulating the same
hardware into Nexus 5x we have the same
number of course they're running on the
same host machine so the only difference
really is the garbage collector when I'm
going to press next
both demos will run at the same time
we're going to start rendering an
animation with a try tracer and at the
top you have o and at the bottom you
have cat see if you can spot the
difference in performance
so we'll service some time it takes 47
seconds for KitKat to render the first
tile yeah but it's a really good it's a
really good tile and again the only
difference we're running the exact same
application the only difference is
effectively the garbage collector so on
all rendering 1 tiles takes about 100 to
500 milliseconds and on K it takes 40 to
50 seconds so two orders of magnitude
slower and if you look at the logs for
on KitKat this is what we see with your
bunch of GC for Alex and I just you know
grab logs for about 10 seconds worth of
computations and you can see we're
constantly stopping all the threads were
blocking the applications all the time
nothing is getting done yeah that's a
lot of a lot of disease and you can see
every time the GC takes 3 to 5
milliseconds so if we look at this trace
on o we can see that even though things
are better they are not quite perfect so
this is this trace here you can see what
the CPUs are doing and from afar it
looks like they are very busy because I
have three worker threads that are
computing those this 3d scene but you
can see there's a lot of cases where the
CPU actually not doing anything there's
holes in inner pipe so if you look at
the app itself we see two interesting
things first of all I've made three
threads that are computing that are
doing the work they are busy chugging
along but from time to time here for
instance the pause and you probably
can't read this but it says full suspend
and then we're not doing anything we're
not doing any computation and the reason
is we have this thread called the heap
test daemon it's basically the
concurrent garbage collector so even
though we're doing concurrent garbage
collection I'm allocating so many
objects in takes so much time for the
concurrent garbage collection to do its
job so here it's taking about 200
milliseconds in wall time that our
threads from time to time have to block
anyway it's not that we want to pass
them because we have to pass them it's
not for the algorithm is because the
garbage collector is still busy and
originally I was spawning more threads
and I was running into real situations
where I had so many threads doing
computation that I was starving the
the thread and it could not run fast
enough so my threads were posing even
more and as a result we're getting only
about 30 to 40% CPU utilization so we're
not using all the compute power that we
have available on the device so the demo
you saw running on oak could actually be
something like three times faster than
that if I was not allocating as much
another thing I wanted to talk about
when you have four minutes left so we'll
go through this very quickly is that you
have to be careful when you do when you
create benchmarks because the garbage
collector can greatly affect the results
of your benchmark once well not really
the benchmark itself but the algorithm
your benchmarking once it's inside your
application might behave very
differently so I'm going to skip some of
this basically a quick recap when you
have a CPU this is the kicks all three
CPU the gold cores we have big cores and
little cause I'm looking at the big
course every core has an l1 cache that's
about 64 kilobyte every cores an l2
cache so 256 kilobyte cache and then
there's an l-3 cache that's shared by
all the cores and this is important
because when you want to access data so
here we have a floater array and I just
want to read one float from that array
the first time we access that float the
CPUs going to go look in the l1 cache
see if it's there if it's not it has to
go fetch it from the l2 if it's not
there it has to go to the l3 and and
final to the RAM and every time we have
to fall back to a higher level cache we
have to do an expensive memory access
that gets more and more expensive as you
go up the chain so accessing the l1
takes only a few nanoseconds accessing
the l2 is going to take four or five
times that amount existing the other is
going to be partly ten times slower and
so on so in a I wrote a demo that
allocates a list of arrays of floats
each array of floats is about four it's
four floats so it's 16 bytes
they are represented by the red lines
here and I will to benchmark basically
using that I'm just going to run some
computations over those those are rise
of floats so if I look at all those
arrays of floats one after the other in
the loop this is what it's going to look
like in RAM all the arrays are neatly
stacked together next to one another in
RAM and I'm using a width of 64 bytes
here for reason that we're going to see
in a minute then I wrote a very simple
you know algorithm so I go through the
array at X 4
I'll run some computation it doesn't
really matter what computations are
running and let's see what happens to
memory so when we access the first float
array in our list it's not anywhere in
our caches it's in RAM it's not in the
l1 or the audio - audio three so we're
gonna go fetch it and put it in the l1
but one optimizations that CPUs have is
that when you need one byte of memory
they are not gonna fetch only one byte
they're going to fetch 64 bytes at a
time so by fetching the first array we
actually fetched the next three or rez
at the same time so then when I want to
read those arrays nothing happens
because they are already in the l1 cache
so this is pretty efficient then we run
our computation now in my test app I've
modified the initialization of the
arrays so that I locate other stuff
between each array and I'm doing this to
basically replicate what happens when
you're garbage collector move things
around or you're fragmentation the app
you should do your allocations over the
lifetime of the application for any
number of reasons that we've seen before
your locations won't be neatly next to
one another in RAM so here I'm
representing this with a bunch of grey
grey lines so if you run the algorithm
again we go fetch our first array but
instead of fetching the other data that
we want we search that great data stuff
that we don't even know what it is but
it's going to be put in the l1 so then
when we want the next array it's not in
the l1 and we have to go back to memory
and get it and so on and so on but again
we're running the same algorithm it's
just now we have to do more the CPUs to
do more work and we can recreate the
same the same thing by spacing out our
eyes even more so that we won't find the
arise in the l2 or the l3 and we can
force the CPU to do even more and not
work so if we run those different
variants of the algorithm where again
all we did was change the way we
allocate the objects we're running the
exact same computations when everything
is neatly stored together in RAM I know
the algorithm takes about I think 150
milliseconds on a pixel 3 so that's the
no thrash and when I space at the
allocation so that we can't find the
data we want in the l1 certainly we're
almost twice as slow we're running the
same exact computations but we'll do it
CPUs is busy going you know to fetch
data in RAM and if I space out the
allocations even more so that we can't
find the data in the l2 now we are over
five times slower
again same exactly the algorithm so if
you're right benchmarks and that's very
good you should you should probably do
that be very careful be aware of the
fact that the numbers you're gonna get
in your benchmark may be very different
than the numbers are gonna get in the
actual app running you know on your
users devices yeah you actually
benchmarking the the CPU access better
there's a few access patterns so and
with that we're done we have six seconds
left a very important thing if you are
interested in what we talked about today
there's a deeper version of this as well
as a lot of the runtime improvements
they're an art overtime by ladies and
engineers on the art team so please
check that out it's at the same time as
the fireside chat which i think is at
11:10 so please go see that talk as well
and that's it thank you
[Applause]
[Music]